there were nine impactful AI
developments in the last few days that I
wanted to tell you guys about from the
frankly startling hey gen video
translation to the Epic new prompt
optimizing paper and from Apple's iax
GPT to open interpreter next GPT yet
more Google Gemini news and even Roblox
AI but I must start with hey Jen you've
probably already heard from AI explained
that hey gen can generate lifelike
videos and is available as a plugin to
chat GPT but how about video language
dubbing well today I got access to their
new Avatar 2.0 feature and I decided to
test it out with Sam Altman not with the
real Sam Altman of course but with his
testimony to the Senate and I want
Spanish language speakers to tell me how
accurate they think this is Mundo
I have been researching three or four
tools including this one to translate my
videos into dozens of languages and I
can't wait to put that into place a time
waits for no man so let me move on to
open interpreter I've been using the
version released five days ago what is
it well an open source code interpreter
here is a brief preview
thank you
[Music]
of course I've been trying it out
intensively and while it's not perfect
it has proven useful I asked it this
download this YouTube video in 1440p EG
using pytube and clip out 2318 2338 save
to desktop naming file Altman vertical
line that's a clip I wanted to use in
this very video now okay it wouldn't
have taken me that long to do it
manually but this process was a few
seconds you agreed to run the code a few
times and here was the end result you
can try to guess why I picked out this
clip from a recent Sam Altman interview
and we weren't set up for that
it's the usage of chatipity decelerating
no
I think it maybe took like a little bit
of a flat line during the summer which
happens for lots of products but it is
doink up
obviously we shouldn't automatically
believe the CEO of the company about how
many people are using his product and I
do think it points to a counter
narrative to the argument that chat
chipity usage is continuing to slow down
into the Autumn you don't have to use
gpt4 either and more generally I think
this points to a change in the way we
will use computers in the near future
and now let's talk about this paper from
Google deepmind I'll have more news
about their Gemini model in a second but
first I found this paper fascinating I
will hopefully be doing a deeper dive
with one of the authors but for now the
big picture is this language models can
come up with optimized prompts for
language models these aren't small
optimizations either and nor do they
work with only one model the paper says
that with a variety of large language
models we demonstrate that the best
prompts optimized by their method
outperform human design prompts by up to
eight percent on a particular math
challenge and by up to 50 on big bench
hard tasks those are long-standing tasks
known for their difficulty for large
language models to massively
oversimplify models like Palm 2 and gpt4
can be given a meta prompt for example
generate a new instruction that achieves
a higher accuracy on a particular task
the language models are then shown how
previous prompts worked out in this
example for a particular task let's
figure it out scored 61 while let's
solve the problem scored 63 out of 100.
this was the mathematics problem down
here and then they're asked generate an
instruction that is different from all
the instructions above and has a higher
score than all the instructions above
the instructions should be concise
effective and generally applicable to
all problems and apparently gpt4 was
particularly good at looking at the
trajectory of optimizations the patterns
and Trends about what produced the
better prompts on a particular task for
example you might start with let's solve
the problem which scored 60.5 and then
the language model would propose
iterations like let's think carefully
about the problem and solve it together
that got 63.2 and you can see the
accuracy gradually going up apparently
at least four math problems Palm 2
preferred concise prompts while GPT
models liked ones that were long and
detailed and nor was it just about the
semantics or meanings of the prompts the
same meanings phrased differently could
get radically different results for
example with palm 2 let's think step by
step got 71.8 whereas let's solve the
problem together has accuracy of 60.5
but then if you put those two together
and say let's work together to solve
this problem step by step you only get
49.4 although semantically its meaning
is just the combination of those two
instructions for the original smart GPT
I used this prompt let's work this out
in a step-by-step way to be sure we have
the right answer that's because it
performed best for gpt4 as you can see
here it doesn't perform best for arm too
although notice it does perform better
than just an empty string what does
perform best well take a deep breath and
work on this problem step by step also
note the difference with beginning your
answer with this prefix or beginning
your question with a prefix anyway I am
hoping to do a deeper dive on this paper
with one of the authors so for now I'll
leave it there suffice to say that
prompt engineering is not a solved
science yet but what was the Gemini news
that I promised you from Google well
this was published just 14 hours ago in
the information Google has as of
yesterday given a small group of
companies access to an early version of
Gemini that is their direct competitor
with openai's gpt4 according to a person
who has tested it Gemini has an
advantage over gpt4 and at least one
respect the model leverages reams of
Google's proprietary data from its
consumer products in addition to public
information straight from the web so the
model should be especially accurate with
all all of those Google search histories
when it comes to understanding users
intentions with particular queries and
apparently compared to gbt4 it generates
fewer incorrect answers known as
hallucinations and again according to
them Gemini will feature a vastly
improved code generating abilities for
software developers although no it says
compared to its existing models it
didn't technically say compared to gpt4
note that Palm 2 didn't score
particularly highly for coding so if
that's the Baseline bear that in mind
the version they're giving developers
isn't their largest version though which
apparently will be on par with gpt4 and
then a first for this channel I'm going
to make a direct prediction using
metaculus I'm going to predict that
there will indeed be at least three
months of third-party safety evaluations
conducted on Gemini before its
deployment I think they finished
training the model sometime in summer so
it will be more like six months if it's
released in December the heart of this
channel is about understanding and
navigating the future of AI so I am
super proud that metaculus are my first
sponsors they have aggregate forecasts
on a range of AI related questions yes
it's free to sign up with the link in
the description so show them some love
and say you came from AI explained
speaking of the future though we learned
this week in the Wall Street Journal
that meta plans to develop llama 3
sometime in early 2024 that will
apparently be several times more
powerful than a llama 2. even more
interesting to me though was this
exchange at a recent meta geni social we
have the compute to train Lama three and
four the plan is for llama 3 to be as
good as gpt4 wow if llama 3 is as good
as GPT 4 will you guys still open source
it yeah we will sorry alignment people
you can let me know in the comments what
you think about that exchange that is of
course in complete contravention of what
senators a Blumenthal and Hawley have
put out this week they released the
bipartisan framework for usai act in it
they actually mentioned deep fakes which
I kind of showed you earlier with hey
Jen but they also focused on AI Audits
and establishing an oversight body that
should have the authority to conduct
audits of companies seeking licenses but
I suspect the people signing up to work
in that auditing office will have to
commit to not working for any of the AI
companies for the rest of their lives
that's going to take a particularly
motivated individual particularly on
public sector pay levels why do I say
that well here's Mustafa Solomon he
recently said this on 80 000 hours well
I'm really stuck I think it's really
hard there is another Direction which
involves academic groups getting more
access and either actually doing red
teaming or doing audits of scale or
audits of model capabilities right
they're the three proposals that I've
heard made and I've been very supportive
of and have certainly explored with
people at Stanford and elsewhere but I
think there's a real problem there which
is if you take the average PhD student
or postdoctoral researcher that might
work on this in a couple years they melt
they may well go to a commercial lab
right and so if if we're to give them
access then they'll probably take that
knowledge and expertise elsewhere
potentially to a competitor I mean it's
an open labor market after all and when
we heard this week that the IRS in
America are going to use AI to catch tax
evasion it made me think that it's going
to increasingly be a cat and mouse game
between governments and Auditors using
AI on the one side and the companies
developing the AI on the other side if
the IRS has an AI that can detect tax
evasion well then a hedge fund can just
make an AI to obscure that tax evasion
seems to me that in all of this Whoever
has the most compute will win and
remember these won't just be single
modality language models anymore to take
one crazy example this week we now have
have smell to text it's a much more
narrow AI trained in a very different
way to GPT models but it matches well
with expert humans on novel smells and
then there's protein chat which I didn't
get a chance to talk about earlier in
the year these so-called protein GPT
enables users to upload proteins ask
questions and engage in interactive
conversations to gain insights and if
that's not enough modalities how about
this this is next GPT a multimodal llm
released two days ago that can go from
any modality to any modality obviously
there should be an asterisk over any
isn't quite any yet but we're talking
about images audio video and then the
output being images audio text video One
obvious question is do we want one model
to be good at everything or do we want
narrower AI That's good at individual
tasks and this links to iax GPT from
Apple now of course I did watch the
iPhone launch but I find this more
interesting this was an exclusive
elusive for the information and they
talk about how Apple's llm is designed
to boost Siri and it almost sounds to me
like open interpreter where you can
automate tasks involving multiple steps
for example telling Siri to create a gif
using the last five photos you've taken
and text it to a friend and this was the
most interesting part of the piece for
me earlier in the article they talked
about how they're spending millions of
dollars a day on iax GPT they're still
quite far behind because apparently iax
GPT beats GPT 3.5 the original Chachi PT
but not gpt4 the focus is on running LMS
on your device with the goal of
improving privacy and performance so I
actuallypt might not be the best llm but
they're pitching it as the best llm on
your phone the model they have at the
moment is apparently too big it's 200
billion parameters even a Macbook might
struggle to run that but they might have
different sizes of iax some small enough
to run on an iPhone of course from a
user point of view that would mean you
can use the model offline unlike say the
chat GPT app let's move on now to a
lighter development albeit one that
might affect hundreds of millions of
people including my nephew apparently
the online game platform Roblox is
bringing in a new AI chat bot that's
going to allow creators to build Virtual
Worlds just by typing prompts and that's
the crazy thing all of this is going to
become intuitive to the Next Generation
children today are just going to expect
their apps to be interactive and
customizable on demand and yes we have
covered a lot today so let me know what
you think I'm going to end with an AI
image that has taken the Internet by
storm as well as a few others from the
same prompter that not as many people
have seen and whatever your thoughts are
on these I think we can all agree that
the world is only going to get more
crazy from here thanks as always for
watching to the end do check out
metaculus in the description and as ever
have a wonderful day